i want to pull up this meme right here
we have of kamala harris because you
know we're talking about people falling
for stupid things there's a meme that's
going around that has to do with the uh
confirmation hearing of brett kavanaugh
camalera says i'll repeat the question
can you think of any laws that give the
government power to make decisions over
the male body that's a good impression
yeah it's conscription next also every
other law because the law governs your
corporeal form they're not like just
making laws about your soul making
decisions about them now this is nuance
that she missed in the question making a
decision about what someone can't do is
a decision about the body making a
decision about what someone has to do
is very very rare and description is one
of them specifically for men and their
bodies and they have to be thrown on the
grenade for the sake of everybody else
and um i think in in
in a real invasion conscription is fine
like if we were actually invaded and
like all of a sudden we're like ah you
know this country has stormed the
beaches and they're killing people like
okay well then everybody rally together
we're gonna die but you know then
vietnam is like not so good but uh
anyway that's not the point the point is
people share this
they they fall for these memes
i i did a segment earlier because i
responded to it by just saying i'm
pro-choice i believe men and women both
have the right to choose whether or not
they are parents and that means child
support is over and they all got
triggered and i i genuinely didn't think
that you know the liberals would would
would get angry over this i thought they
would agree and be like yes people no
they were like men have no choice and no
say in the matter women get the choice
that's it and i and the reason i bring
that up is
for one the there's a lot of memes they
fall for but the other thing is i think
you found a basic argument here when
talking to your your typical liberal
pro-choice person that shows they'll
argue against choice instantly if you
say those words no more child support
instantly like might have no choice
it's like oh okay i thought you were
pro-choice
no i mean they're not we've talked about
it before it's literally just them being
pro-abortion they don't care about
choice when it comes to literally any
other issue and i said this on the show
yesterday but there really aren't other
issues that we discuss in that form so
if i say a person should be able to
choose to own a gun you don't call me
pro-choice you call me pro-gun okay well
if you're saying someone should be able
to choose to have an abortion you are
pro-abortion like they're pro-abortion
um i don't know because i'm pro-choice
when it comes to religion but i'm not
pro-religion hmm that is an interesting
point that's an interesting point but i
think if there were people who were like
trying to ban religion we'd probably
call them anti-religion and if you were
on the ark if you were on the side of
the debate saying that religions should
be
legalized or normalized or something
they probably would call you
pro-religion and that's a hypothetical
but i'm talking about like the actual
political issues we deal with and there
really aren't other ones that we have
the discussion about where we just say
like they're in favor of choice and
don't discuss what they're talking about
choosing like even even when it comes to
educational vouchers we call it school
choice we don't just call them
pro-choice at what point can we refer to
the like the left culture war grifters
as anti-disestablishmentarian
establishments
almost got it
i mean i think that word specifically
referred to some like church thing
there's like a british movement to i for
the
anti-disestablishment so it's like it
must have had something to do with the
the church of england but i was just
thinking like i was thinking like we're
just we're anti-establishment people we
like we oppose the establishment
institutions and so these people oppose
the people who are anti so it's
anti-anti-establishment yeah they want
they want to come together they want to
anti just establishmentarians
they would say like well actually you're
on the side of the establishment we're
against these thousands that's why every
fast food company in the country has the
same opinions as me right that's why we
we're we work for jeff bezos's company
did you guys see that there was an op-ed
in the washington post arguing for
george washington university to change
its name i did see that like the
washington post right above it and i'm
just like
you know we can all sit here and laugh
about it but it's kind of like
you know with the with the gas prices
story and the oil and gas leases
we're on we're on a big boat let's hit
an iceberg
and as it's sinking
there are a bunch of people claiming
it's not really sinking and you're
stupid and it's a or that it's a good
thing that it's sinking meanwhile the
the captain and his crew are looting the
silverware and jumping into lifeboats
sending all of their valuables to
another boat and we're sitting here
yelling like
they're but we're all trapped on this
boat they're also finding some people on
the boat here here here's some
silverware go tell everyone else that
everything's fine so then the person's
like thanks for the silverware they go
back onto the boat and they're like hey
guys i guess everything's fine and then
as by the time they come back the dude's
gone with all the rest of the silverware
like they're bribing people to lie to us
right now
is the question that kamala harris when
she asks a question like this is she
really dumb or is she conniving oh she's
connected i think it's both maybe both i
think it's both so i think she's
conniving i think she's intelligent in
the way she connives in some respects
but on this issue i think she's actually
probably just dumb i would not be
surprised if she hasn't questioned this
particular perspective and yeah if you
had said responded in lockstep
conscription she would just been nodded
in stunned silence can i just point out
that there are a lot of laws prohibiting
men from doing specific things with
their bodies in public gross things yes
like
any laws that give the government power
to make decisions about the male body
yes
i don't know we should get into it on
the after show
it's a good thing like and like i said
every single law governs your corporeal
form like they're not making laws about
what you can do with your soul they're
like they're making
laws about what you do with your body
forget this get this they're not going
to convict you when i when i respond to
this meme by saying that i was
pro-choice and that men should choose to
be able to you know
like dave chappelle made that joke he's
like you can if you can choose to kill
it i can choose to at least abandon it
and everyone left and i kid you not the
responses i got were the man made a
choice
and he got a woman pregnant and now it's
his responsibility
he can't just claim and i was like wait
a minute what they're saying is all
women are raped like every act of sex is
actually raped because women never
consent to sex they're saying but i mean
like literally they're saying women get
a choice and men don't what if they're
for the exact same reasons but they were
making pro-life arguments as to why men
don't get a choice and i'm just like
what are they just anti-men
like if i was like if you make a
pro-choice argument and i agree with you
but then you just all of a sudden give
me the pro-life version of it he he made
a choice and he could have used birth
control i kid you not they said condoms
and birth control are readily available
it's his fault he has to be responsible
for it and i'm like
are you are you what we talked about
this we talked about this yesterday at
some point even if they don't do so in
in the totality of the position at some
point left wingers come back around to a
right-wing position they get so far to
the left so the other day i was joking
that they'll say things like
well if abortion's illegal then men
should be forced to take care of the
children they're like yes every
conservative agrees with that and on
this point when you when you talk about
men and child support all of a sudden
they're very big fans of personal
responsibility and not having sex with
someone you wouldn't have a child with
there was a a bill in florida to ban
abortion for 15 weeks so a democrat
proposed an amendment that would require
men to pay child support at 15 weeks and
then i was just like
awesome yeah i don't understand you know
can the pro-life people want marriage
they don't want they want child support
from conception yeah also they they want
familial support before conception
also like what kind of insane society do
we live in where the political solution
is oh like let's legislate that someone
should have to pay
for his pregnant woman's unborn child
like there used to be a social mechanism
for that right people would get married
and have kids and a man would be ashamed
if he was not taking care of the child
that he had created with a woman
cultural enforcement and cultural decay
yeah
you have to legislate things that
society doesn't do
so if people aren't supporting their
kids and you're like okay we gotta we
got we have to tell them they have to
culture used to have you know is what uh
jordan peterson called cultural and what
no enforcement organization
and then
just like every other circumstance where
the left has no idea what's going on
they assume what it means without asking
questions or doing any basic research
and then they're like
jordan peterson wants to force women to
marry incels
that's literally not what he's talking
about no actually i i do
yeah no i mean i if i see you outside
protesting my event shotgun wedding i'm
finding it in south you're marrying him
that's right bucko
if you don't clean your room you will
marry an insult i was thinking how
horrible it would be if the man decided
if the baby was going to be aborted or
not and it wasn't the woman's choice it
was the man's choice and the woman's
like no like in the man's like i've
decided because if the woman decides and
the man goes no the woman does it well
in this this dude there's the idea that
there's a video where a guy is on his
knees screaming and crying like bawling
his eyes out screaming please don't kill
my child and he has no say whatsoever no
choice and if the woman says you know
what i am going to keep it you have to
pay for it the man gets no choice
well and ian i hear what you're saying
but and that also debunks the entire
narrative from the left oh they got us
what did they did we got knocked off
youtube did we really i don't know but
keep talking okay so my point is what
you're saying ian also demonstrates
i mean it completely debunks the
left-wing argument that what
conservatives want here is just just to
control women's bodies right because if
that were the case what conservatives
would be saying is well women should get
abortions abortions are fine as long as
a man decides if our investment was
truly in just controlling women's bodies
but obviously yeah that'd be the worst
the worst example of it i do think this
conversation really we have it very
logically at least as maybe it's not
because we're men it's just in general
we're having this conversation logically
i think a lot of it isn't like an
emotional thing that
women need an extra force of empowerment
in society because they do have the
burden of carrying the baby and so
just to say like to cut it into like
segments and be like well i don't know
this is how i feel so i
that's why i consider myself pro-choice
on the issue because i've never i've
never i'm not a woman i've never been in
that situation where i felt like
something like that could happen to me
well so i agree with part of that
obviously i'm not pro-choice but i think
you're absolutely correct that the
discussion become can become
over-intellectualized and when you want
to you know sort of cut to the moral
bedrock of whether something is right or
wrong that makes sense
but someone doesn't get an abortion
because they heard the violinist
argument and we're convinced by it it's
not on our end the drop off has nothing
to do with us really yeah this is
youtube interesting chat's still live
jets chat's like the internet still
works yeah interesting yeah there's
nothing wrong with the internet so
youtube's basically shut us down or or
it could just be a glitch this happens
oh yeah it's a glitch yeah yeah yeah how
awesome wait it's a glitch
they're like they're making fun of
kamala again shut up shut him down
yeah she's got her big red yeah cause
like i'm on my cell phone
you know i can't even load chat oh
that's crazy yeah okay so it's like
definitely youtube chicken city is still
alive ian what did you say this time i
can't chicken city's still alive i think
so yeah zooby's live let's see if
zooby's still alive i think if chicken
city is live that's that's something
special shout out to zubi with his 24
hour live stream oh wait zooby is also
frozen frozen i think youtube itself is
down yeah i can't load youtube at all
hold on i i
are you on the wi-fi though oh man yeah
mine just mine just froze too oh
something are you using sell signal
though i'm using i'm using cell yeah
yeah i'm on cell and i can't connect
don't blame me no it's not my fault
okay so let's see chicken
i think chicken city's down yeah it's on
youtube zen yeah i'm about confirmed on
that one
lydia the stream is down whoa the chat
is on fire
are all the live streams down early it
looks like it yeah i just checked three
and they're not working yeah none of
them were but the wi-fi is working and
everything's loading yeah yeah it's on
them
oh well maybe youtube's being uh being
attacked chicken city looks like it is
live i thought so too but it was dark oh
i got a live one i got a live one
i found a live stream yeah chicken city
appears to be working huh we should uh
just have a back up chicken city yeah
you can hop over
quick everybody let's go to chicken city
oh maybe i just saw a buffered thing i
think they buffered 15 seconds when i
click on a stream let me see if it keeps
going
technical glitches the segment where the
stream goes down it was unbelievable
i wonder why this is happening it's
sheamus fault probably it's probably
because will chamberlain's here because
i've been on the show a lot of times and
it hasn't frozen but he's here what was
that last time this happened
uh i don't remember i remember it did
freeze on e and it's not about vanguard
and blackwell that's right yeah
was it poso i don't remember yeah i
think it was can we take this
opportunity to swear our brain no no
[Laughter]
we can keep talking
i'm still going to keep the show going
we'll be we'll be uploading this to
rumble rumble yeah i should upload this
one to rumble because it's actually yeah
it's a good idea pretty junked yeah well
i'm going to upload the whole episode to
all podcast platforms and i'll use the
raw file to make clips cool how's family
life well oh yeah they just hey it's
going
back we're back did you hear my question
yeah i wonder how much of that dropped
off yeah
disappeared all you know sheamus saying
all like his bank personal information
honestly dude i've never had a gaffe
like that before so yeah so uh
everybody everybody that was youtube not
us yeah not us
our internet is completely fine and i
believe chicken city never went down
that's right so you could have been
there we we used the same internet feed
for a couple different things and we had
so this was a youtube thing we should
have run out
there were other streams that were
awesome i checked zubi's live stream and
that was also paused and it's still
paused yeah it's youtube's going on yeah
youtube's under attack
youtuber
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm
we'll see you all there